Tony, can I tell them
our, our disagreement? Yes.
I thought you'd be interested because we had very. Yes, yes, it's important.
You'd have,
it may be interesting for you.
So, so
I, I, I personally don't think
that pluralism,
religious pluralism, or religiously pluralist position, which says
all faiths
are equally true
and equally valid ways
of
accessing the divine.
I don't think it's intellectually coherent.
I think it's muddled.
So, so, that's, that's one thing and we can, we can, we can discuss that and I'm prepared
to. Do you mean intellectually, when you say intellectually, my, you don't me asking,
not, not that that is in the air, but when you say intellectually muddled. I, I mean. As opposed to just
not something you agree with, as it were.
Well. No, no, you know what I mean,
because obviously you do believe. Well, I disagree. That, it's not, as a matter of fact, what I believe, but obviously
you could believe that all faiths.
You could believe that, but I don't think, I don't think it's a coherent
it's a, it's not a coherent position, therefore, I think it's a wrong position.
I could put it, I could put it strongly, like, and partly I believe because
religious traditions make truth claims
and those truth claims are not compatible often
and
so
the second thing
I, I think something like a soft exclusivism
is actually
the, the most compelling
position.
Two,
I don't think
that non-exclusivism of faiths
is
the most important aspect in their contribution to, to peace.
I think
that commitment
to respect the dignity,
fundamental dignity of each person
and commitment to care
for another person,
whether your faith is exclusive or non-exclusive is more important for the peace processes
than
whether you think that that person's belief system
is true
or, or not. Right, but I would, I would, I would agree with that. I could. But I would say, I would say, but aren't
you more likely
the less,
the less vehement your
exclusivity, you know what I mean, the more vehement your view
that your religion is exclusive, is that not more,
more likely
to mean that you, you, you don't regard
those things as important.
Right, that, that, there are kinds of exclusivisms like in Northern Ireland, Protestants
of Northern Ireland, they're a very good example.
It was exclusivism, which said
basically, I think, in simple terms, God loves only us.
God doesn't love
the nasty Catholics.
Right, they're papists and so forth. They're out of the purview of God's love. I remember I
was there when I was talking about
Christ's universal love, for instance,
and their hands went up,
went up in the air and they said "No, that's not true.
God's love is limited to certain crowd of folks and it doesn't apply to the Catholic."
Now, if you have that view, exclusivist view,
I think that that's really pernicious
and completely unacceptable and it
undermines
reconciliation process totally and fosters violence,
but if you have exclusivist faith, which says
I ought to love every person because God loves every person.
I ought to respect every person because everyone is made in the image of God,
then exclusivity
will not be
in conflict
with peace process.
And I would, I would agree with that it's just that I think that, that, sorry,
let me come and reserve.
Can I just? Yeah. There we go. That's good.
On
the question
of pluralism as coherent, my own view
is that the truth claims
are all untestable by mortal man, from what, and that having, have,
accepting that fact
is, for me, a basis for pluralism,
which says they are all
credible and
indistinguishable at and also
epistemological level as, as faiths,
as ways of relating to God.
Yeah, and, and, and my conclusion would, would be that they're not strictly testable because faiths
are different things than
kind of
empirical, faith statements are different kinds of statements that empirical statements,
but I wouldn't say for that reason
that I cannot affirm them as truth claims and therefore have to say
they're fifteen truth claims that are different and all are equally true because I can't test any one of them.
What instead I say
because of this limited ability to test
is that I need to hold and have to hold
religious convictions
with a, a certain provisionality,
with a certain sense of the mystery beyond,
which simply says my
thing that I think is true
is such that
I cannot
assert my knowledge as absolute about something
that
is inherently beyond the capacity of human beings fully to grasp.